all right welcome everybody to session
14 of classic metal class this time
scott and i
wanted to tackle something that we've
been talking about and kicking around
for a long time and i titled it
meta metal
thematics and i almost said fanatics but
and and so meta anytime that you've got
that it means that there's like a higher
level or it's applying to itself and
that's what we're looking at we're
looking at songs
that talk about or articulate or
reference the heavy metal whatever we
want to call it lifestyle
ethos idea
and i'm bringing in a little bit of uh
scholarship on this uh you know if you
can see it uh here we gotta get it
it's hard to get on on the the zoom
thing it's it's heavy metal a cultural
sociology by dina weinstein a early and
still pretty good resource on the
sociology of heavy metal
i really like her stuff and someday
maybe we'll have her on the show if i
can she's down in chicago so maybe i can
you know get in touch with her and she
says a couple things that are you know
they jibe with our experience i think of
those who
were around in the the 80s in particular
but also you know going back into the
70s and then going forward into the 90s
and 2000s
and she has some really interesting
things to say some of what she has to
say is a bit dated so it doesn't maybe
apply to the contemporary metal scene
for example you know that heavy metal is
tied in with a youth ethos
i think some genres are but obviously
you know when many of us metalheads are
in our 40s 50s 60s maybe not so much
youth lifestyle part
exactly yeah well and we're not partying
every day you know
like maybe some of us did back then
either but so um meta metal thematics
and metal identity
this is something we've been thinking
about for a long time
and they're you know metal songs by
virtue of what's going on with the
instrumental parts are already metal so
it's not as if ever it's not as if
there's a meta metal thematic
in the instrumental side it's on the
lyric side so a song that you know has
heavy metal in the title or like you
know saxons denim
leather is talking about a lifestyle and
a community which we're gonna look at in
a bit
um
and it's not the only genre and i was
hoping scott could help me out with this
where there's a metathematic and i
thought okay there's blues songs about
the blues there's all these blues songs
where it's the something something blues
right and there's a lot of lyrical
content where they're talking about
having the blues or what the blues is
about there's a lot of rock songs about
rock and there's some overlap with metal
songs about metal since metal is a genre
of rock and there's a lot of rapping
about rap in rap
what other i mean are there jazz songs
about jazz
lyrically or are are there other
genres that you can think about like
well if we go back to it don't mean a
thing if it ain't got that swing all
right oh yeah that's a good example yeah
you know um
um
i mean most jazz standards were radio
hits in the 30s and 40s so okay so the
jazz musicians the real early ones
especially when we got to charlie parker
and and got
um got to bebop
um
they were just playing
basically uh improvising over songs
everybody knew on the radio now we're so
far behind i mean i'm just behind we're
so far
ahead of that that none of us remember
those songs being on the radio right of
course yeah but but back then
um but um
i'm trying to think it will like you
know um
well you know take five i think people
are familiar with it's kind of a play on
word because it's the songs in that time
signature yeah um but you know uh
lyrical jazz
um
[Music]
no i mean it's it they made it may have
been talking about the era like we saw
what frank sinatra the songs that he
made famous yeah they had to do with
whatever it had to do with that time
about
um
i guess the content's not
uh
i guess rarely it would be about you
know
the style or the feel
you know now that i think about it
though like punk
there are punk songs that reference punk
right
and well that's a good one of course
yeah and and are there pop songs that
well duran duran pop trash right so
there are some pop songs although
they're doing it in kind of an ironic
way
um that's a great album by the way i
like that one a lot i i'm actually you
know people don't know this that much
about me but i'm i'm a massive duran
duran fan since childhood
and people you know they're how can you
like duran duran and metal well you know
different things for different times and
and uh yeah well they're they're one of
the greats yeah and i think it kind of
reaches different parts of yourself
maybe
yeah um
i'm trying to think uh
you know like rock and roll bands well
we're an american band
um that's an interesting one yeah
so but but
i don't think the lyrics i think with
metal
i think the lyrics are about
a certain lifestyle of you know and
they're pretty consistent like you know
if they're singing if you have 10
different bands singing about
uh the same topic like partying or
or having sex or whatever and
they may be using different words but
the themes are
pretty cohesive from you know from band
to band
um i think i think it depends somewhat
on what we could call sub genre and i
don't mean like getting into like say
black metal versus sludge metal versus
that i i'm talking about stuff that was
a little bit less clearly defined back
in the 80s you know donna weinstein for
example talks about there being
basically three main
genres on the spectrum with thrash speed
on one side light as she l-i-t-e she
calls it on the other that would include
like you know cinderella or poison and
then heavy metal classic heavy metal in
the middle and bands like rat kind of
straddling the two
you know um except maybe being over like
closer to the speed metal side and and
bands being able to transition so like
you just shifts you know at a certain
point to become more uh like like the
the speed metal thrash metal and you
know like on painkiller um oh yeah right
there so there are so if if you take a
theme like partying
um the way that rat sings about partying
will have a lot in common with the way
van halen talks about partying um and
wasp talks about partying and and you
know but once we start getting into like
maybe
dio iron maiden judas priest partying if
it's being talked about becomes
something maybe a bit darker
yeah well
dio's a good example i mean he does do
the rock anthems like we rock yeah um
but i don't think he he didn't i mean
that's why he left richie blackmore when
rainbow was going pop he's you know he
he kept saying you know i didn't want to
sing love songs
when you when you party in a dio song
sooner or later um somebody gets in
trouble
you know
that's
it's not hey let's have a party it's all
fun let's drink some booze you know
until till up comes the sun or whatever
other rhyme we want to put together it's
more like well if you open up that door
what's behind it
[Music]
that's a good point yeah yeah
so you brought up something really
important there are certain
key themes to
heavy metal and
we we sat down a couple days ago me and
scott and came up with with a
list that we thought captured a lot of
these and perhaps you know people can
can help us uh
further refine and define this so there
is the partying thing right um hedonism
in general what weinstein calls the
dionysiak
element of it
you know so think about you know think
about kiss and van halen and bands like
that drugs drinking
having sex you know meaningless sex but
that's a lot of fun
but then there's also a different side
to the sexuality where it can be kind of
romantic you know
desire heroes love you know one-on-one
kind of thing which is often tied in
with a oh i lost her you know um as a
matter of fact uh uh which finder
general has i loved her and i lost her
um there's there's songs about um
accepts losing more than you ever had is
another song like that except it has
some pretty romantic stuff you know and
oodles though just a romantic he just
looks like such a romantic
a roly-poly romantic tank you know tank
actually has that song wasting my life
away
um off of the honor album and it's about
a guy who's you know he's got he's in a
bad relationship and he's wondering you
know how can she hurt me this much and
you know it's uh it's two in the morning
and i've got tears in my eyes and then
the next verse is four in the morning
and i've got tears in my eyes
so there's there's a lot of that it's
not just let's let's get it laid as much
as possible um
sorry on that subject too before i
forget um that that as well some bands
talked about the dangers of it like
dawkins kiss of death i think is about
sleeping around and catching aids i
think right is that the kiss of death
that could be wow she promised paradise
like he hired a hooker and he
he got you know i don't think they
explicitly said that but they're dancing
around the fact that i mean it could be
hopeless too right yeah um so so uh
once in a while they would
uh they would write the dangers of it
like i said before like ozzie would
write suicide solution yeah and remember
that went to court
the family because it was misinterpreted
right yeah i think it rested beyond the
realms of death um judas priest's song
which is not about um
partying so much but it's about a sad
case as well you know a kid who becomes
inaccessible you could say i want to
come back to mark's question in a minute
but let's let's talk about some of these
other things as well there's also the
fantasy aspect you know dealing with the
with magic and the occult and i actually
put down rainbows because uh ronnie
james duo i don't think can write an
album that doesn't have a rainbow in it
somewhere um and and that's an important
aspect as well and sometimes it extends
to nights and you know fighting and
stuff like that um and then there's a
you can say that there's distinguishable
from that a
not necessarily satanist in the sense of
like endorsing
worshipping satan but rather
you know
a concern that's
horror oriented you think about black
sabbath's early stuff they're not
actually saying hey it's so wonderful to
worship the devil they're saying oh this
is really terrible we might get caught
in this kind of thing
now by the time that you get to like
venom
i would say there's an interesting
endorsement but you know venom also has
a a uh
entire album called that war with satan
where they're like screw god but also
screw the devil you know
um and that's an important part and then
there's the
aggression toughness rebellion
criminality fighting
um kind of aspect to it as well you know
running free is a perfect example of
that breaking the law yo that's another
good example yeah yeah and then um being
misunderstood and alone
very common it can be whiny you know
like ozzy's stuff ozzy for a while could
not do an album without complaining
about being misunderstood
you know right um or it could be but you
know breaking the law is an example of
that right why am i breaking the law
because i'm stuck on my own and you know
i go from town to town and nobody loves
me
um and then another thing that i think
is there from the very beginning in
black sabbath in bloester cult and in
some of these other bands is
reacting against a world that has gone
mad
you know a world that is
unfair
uh oriented towards uh you know uh war
or
aggression or exploitation
and sort of like saying i'm not gonna
buy into this man and that's something
that metal has in common with punk right
yeah the themes
that's a good point because
well punk is kind of uh
a badge of honor
being rebellious right yeah because like
people
because who is the monk artist that
recently it came out that he voted for
trump and instead of all the punks
getting mad at him for voting for trump
they said that's the most punk thing you
can do
i suppose yeah in a way not just a badge
of honor but almost like a requirement
you could be ostracized from the
community if you're considered to be a
poser conformist or
something like that then there's famous
yeah there's there's an interesting
tension there because how do you
maintain
that but the another key theme and the
one that we're going to focus on a lot
and then we'll come back to mark's
question about partying
um
playing and losing yourself in the music
itself and the fan band connection
there's this interesting passage
in
donna weinstein's heavy metal sociology
that says the social dimension of heavy
metal is a transaction between the
artists audiences and mediators that
enable the genre to exist a transaction
is a set of exchanges between
participants each participant does
something distinctive to contribute to
the transaction
and receive something in turn from the
other participants and i think she's
completely right about this you know
um this is an important dimension and so
these meta metal songs helped us to
figure out what does it mean to be a
metal head what does it mean to be
involved in this and it's not as if
there was like a neat cut and dried
answer to it it was like a whole range
of
questions and answers so let's let's
let's take some of these questions
before we move on to the identity thing
mark says would you say there's a
difference between the way
metal bands sing about partying and how
partying is sung about in other genres
good question
um
i mean insofar as metal overlaps with um
other kinds of hard rock i would say
there's there's a similarity there right
and as metal becomes more extreme
uh in in you know the late 80s early 90s
i think there's modes of partying
which um reflect that and that would you
know like you wouldn't find um
you could find soft metal bands talking
ironically about s m practices right um
but they don't you don't get the idea
that they really are into it or know
that much about it
but if venom starts singing about it
they're probably talking from experience
you know um
what do you think scott
it's a great question um so
first of all take a rock band like
poison
um
i would say they sing about
excessive partying and but
if you take different genres um the
difference between it like if you took
a say a singer songwriter like a pop
singer songwriter
it's not done to excess there might be a
line in it like we had a we had one too
many drinks last night or
you know but we found ourselves in bed
or something like that yeah or you know
they'll they'll be talking about maybe a
hangover but
i think the difference with metal is
it's
almost hyperbolic i mean it's like yeah
it's
such an extreme that like you know
revisiting these lyrics is like who
would survive that
you know
and you know
so in other i think in other styles of
music i mean you know
with jazz standards if you're some of
the old ones it's always classy you know
it's always you know sipping on a
martini or something it's like this
isn't though what's that and blues isn't
though blues is blues is pretty raunchy
you know
well blues yeah
and in country too
oh right right
yeah it was about you know
there's got to be a line about jack
daniels you know being your best friend
because your girl left you
um but again it's not that that's more
you the person
in those
in those songs is drinking for a
different reason
in rock it's you're we're going to have
a great time we're going to party and
you know
um
a great example that everybody's working
for the weekend right oh god think about
the culture that that represents so
that's the lover boy song yeah um and
it's you know the work week we're all
doing whatever we're doing you know
maybe working in an office maybe you
know
working on our cars or stuff like that
and that sucks but the weekend comes and
now everybody's having a great time
it's that's yeah and that would fit
under kind of an anthematic
sort of yeah that is definitely an
anthem
i actually actually texted that to andy
my wife when we were in the middle of
you know a rather tough week and i just
texted her the video
and she thought it was it was kind of a
nice pick-me-up now carl has a really
great question here
um a very deep question what is it about
not just metal but rock and roll in
general that tends to lead people to
hang their identity on it
i've always found this an interesting
phenomenon people may have been into
blues or jazz back in the 20s or 30s and
been heavy jazz or blues enthusiasts but
somewhere along the line when rock and
roll was born the idea that this is a
lifestyle to which i can subscribe
really took hold i'm thinking about the
greasers of the 50s later the ideas of
mods and rockers and you know primarily
in england but with imitators in other
places the biker culture later heavy
metal and punk rock identity
why do you feel we as a culture
descended into what arguably could be
termed as an identity crisis to which
these identities presented themselves as
a solution so this is a there's a lot of
moving parts here uh you want to take a
stab at it first scott sure
um i've always said this when i was in
high school
um
there were the outcast kids that didn't
really have a lot of friends or maybe
social skills
and um
they were all diehard metal fans and i
think a lot of the content about being a
rebel or uh
it's kind of like in
metal lyrics
create a a complete fantasy world to go
into but also there's something about
you know other people weren't listening
to heavy metal in my school i wasn't you
know
some outcasts i didn't really have
a lot of friends in high school actually
so
but when you went home and put on the
headphones and put on maiden it's kind
of like
there's something
in my mind and
i you know i talked to my friends about
it's kind of like a place for
misunderstood people to go
this understood people they would go
there and then they found their people
so we always talk about the not the with
a denim jacket with all the
patches
and you know
we would go to the mall and walk around
or see somebody we didn't know but with
one of those jackets and we would wow
man that triumph thing that's a cool one
and it was kind of uh i think you know
carl's completely right it became
a culture in itself where it's like well
you you understand me as well yeah and
um
so you know i have a complimentary sort
of background experience in this which
is that um
for me it wasn't being like totally on
my own and listening to metal it was
rather that it was part of a
countercultural community that i could
then
uh transition into and belong to it i
really like the music i like the
heaviness of it i like you know the
guitar solos i like singing along to the
bass lines and stuff like that
but i
um
you know basically from like
eighth grade all the way through high
school
and then it was similar there were other
people when i was in the army who were
into metal too and we had a little
subculture there
but it was usually like there would be
like some some older kids and there'd be
like you know the burnouts and other
other kids who were kind of uh tough and
maybe criminals actually some of them
were
and
you know
instead of hanging out with the the
jocks or the popular kids or whatever
other clicks you you'd hang out with
these people because they like to do
you know kind of the things that i like
to do which is uh
um
party and and you know talk about the
music and uh
play rough sports and
things like that and sometimes you know
um
although it didn't happen as often as in
music videos hook up you know right so
and there and there'd often be like an
older cadre
of of people who are like initiated in
the music so like you look at some of
the the songs that were
going to focus on those were coming out
you know in the
late 70s early 80s as we were moving
from middle school into high school
and so maybe you know like in my case
growing up in in rural wisconsin i
hadn't heard a lot of these bands
because they weren't on the radio there
would be a there would be older people
who would kind of initiate you into oh
you like that you should listen to this
man you know somebody would have an
older brother to have a whole bunch of
albums and you'd sit in there they're
right
it was always in the basement you know
you'd sit in their basement uh a room
where there was a big stereo and
and listen to that and it was scott was
putting out an identifier you know the
the way you dressed the way that you
talked
the things that you valued
now um that doesn't quite get to
about culture and i think that that carl
is is on to something here
are the reason why there could be these
counter cultural subcultures that were
identified with music has to do with the
rest of the culture not giving
people what they wanted and this again
is something that weinstein talks about
a lot in britain you know metal was
essentially blue collar
um i mean it's not necessarily now but
it definitely was then you would hear it
in in what were called working man's
claws
right that's where a lot of these bands
cut their teeth and these would be you
know where you could buy beer and maybe
uh some cheap rail drinks and that was
about it
and you know you could listen to it in
clubs here as well and i think that
there's probably different answers for
different kinds of metal and there's
probably different answers for different
musical genres like the punk rock thing
sometimes intersected with metal but
sometimes it's very antagonistic with
metal you know i remember
the days when you know metal heads you
say you know punk is junk heavy metal
rules right
and i didn't participate in this but out
in delafield uh you know just
down the road from from where i was
living
the high schoolers who are heavy metal
heads and and punk used to get together
and beat the crap out of each other you
know over
it's like they're championing their
music and it also is something that kind
of flowed out of their music you
wouldn't catch you know soft rock
aficionados getting getting together and
rumbling with the metal heads that's not
their their their sort of deal right
um so they're they're i think it really
depends on which subculture we're
talking about i don't know if that's a
decent answer but um
well that that brings it kind of lends
the
the question you and i asked yeah
that you know
did metal make the lifestyle or did
metal attract the lifestyle yeah and
which i think is both it's a dialectical
um sort of thing and it builds off of
each other
not quite generationally because we're
talking about something happening within
the scope of like one and a half
generations
uh right
but you can talk about
something like maybe
semi-generations like you know the metal
of the world of 1979
which would include
say you know judas priest being at the
top motorhead the scorpions
um
uh black sabbath kind of coming back
into things ufo kind of going down van
halen definitely on on the the front of
things
that's a different generation or
sub-generation than say metal in 1983
you know or metal in 1980 what would be
the equivalent of that four years 1987.
i think that there's some important
transitions that are
taking place in in the the scene the
lifestyle you know
and you know i think
also the people that are writing the
music for the most part
the metalheads i think
um they attract
the reason they attract
people is because they're
you know as it turns out they were a lot
like us
right
so they're actually writing about this
stuff because that's what they're
thinking although you take a band like
kiss
and they sing about stuff that they
never do like drinking like cold gin and
taking you know and just partying and
we know that paul and jean don't drink
we know that although they they
certainly you know were doing a lot of
uh sexual relationships back then before
they were
and they would have the uh
the thinly
disguised you know what do you call
where you know
wink wink you know like uh yeah
well
let's put the x in sex i mean i was just
laughing because i was thinking maybe
ace did enough drinking and drugs for
the entire band though you know
how is that guy still walking
yeah there's there's this this um
what was that it was a uh shock jock
kind of guy on tv
who um it was late at night because he
swore on tv and he had ace freely on for
one of his shows this is the guy who
later lost uh his show because he
accused
fake neo-nazis of having like you know
beaten him up and and written a swastika
on him um was it mor martin downey yeah
yeah morton downey yeah ace showed up on
that and it's you watch that and you're
like yeah this guy is pickled you know
um
so
let's uh to take carl's other company
says i remember when the metal folks
started going to the punk shows
metallica's garage days ep
all of a sudden the misfits were cool
and the metal folks started showing up
at killing joke shows where you never
would have seen that before i do think
the tribal thing we're discussing here
is very relevant yeah i think i think
that's that's quite true and we do see
this even in genres of metal you know
debates about you know even in
weinstein's
analysis is light metal
pop metal whatever we want to call it is
it really metal or not you know
or should we push that off into a
different uh genre
yeah it's that's a tough one because
we'll take white stakes you would
probably consider white snake yeah yeah
but but we're talking about somebody
that was in one of the most
legendary
metal bands ever he was a deep purple
yeah yeah coverdale and um
and
i think white snake is metal but i
wouldn't say they're like the paradigm
if you put white snake up against iron
maiden and you say which of these is the
most metal iron maiden hands down right
right even if you put them against like
say
van halen or rat i would say either of
those two bands are more metal than
white snake but white snake is
definitely in the boundary you know
yeah and i think i think we have to
remember how much image had to do with
stuff yeah um like and the confusion
that's caused by having long hair
if you had long hair and you were
playing something that was kind of hard
yep for a while you could call it metal
molly hatchet
tried to get in on that and i remember
being so disappointed when i got one of
their albums because people had told me
that they're heavy metal and i'm playing
and it's just this southern rock stuff
and i'm like that's right the hell is
this stuff but they dressed the part
they were like jumping on the bandwagon
mark says there's weird intersections
between politics and metal sub-genres
the different positions
thrash metal versus black metal culture
hold to nazism yeah contemporary well
not just contemporary going all the way
back into the 90s
stuff metal positions itself is counter
culture but it's interesting and often
disappointing to see it
associated with vicious and reactionary
political views um
yeah that i mean that does that does
happen
um and i think that's that's mostly a
product of uh the
what we you know nowadays label
technically is the extreme genres you
know
you find that more in there i mean i
don't think you're going to find that
too much of that in traditional the the
new wave of traditional heavy metal or
in power metal um
it's it's more in other sub-genres
um well that's interesting
i just want to say um
uh the
politics
now yeah
any genre if if
an artist is going like doing a
political record i don't want to hear it
that's you know like if it's a metal
album like i remember so
like
what's that then again war pigs
you know
yeah okay but i mean yeah
iron maiden gets pretty political too
you know
but it's it's more progressive politics
think about like um
concerns about the environment or about
uh the possibility of nuclear war and
stuff like that
a lot of a lot of fans got pissed off at
iron maiden
when you know they'd start talking about
stuff on stage during concerts yeah and
you know that that bothers me
um
on either side like when they the singer
starts ranting about something
especially a sensitive subject yeah and
i'm thinking wow you're really isolating
you know especially when the you know
you're isolating half of your audience
you know you know that don't agree with
you and um and that's a really important
point the metal so it's interesting
again i'm going back to weinstein she
considers the concert to be the
preeminent locus for metal and what what
is it really about it's about the
connection between the band and the
audience but what scott's talking about
is a split within the audience that can
happen through the actions of the band
so if you
start saying you get up on stage and you
start you know spouting stuff about you
know trump or biden or things like that
and half the audience is like yeah screw
them man and then the other half of the
audience is like well screw you you know
it's it's producing a very different
concert experience that
metal needs a
a
experience of of not not necessarily
unity but community
in order to really work and that's i oz
fest
10 11 years ago when i went i was so
disappointed because there was they had
screens set up all over the place and
they had like booths set up that were
just uh you know it would show uh
george bush with a hitler mustache
saying same thing
and the whole like in between
um you could buy t-shirts that's like
you know
um
you know
really nasty things about george bush or
i think that was probably the maybe it
was longer ago i'm thinking but you know
that really turned me off because i'm
not there for that reason i'm not there
to you know this is our escape this
isn't like we're gonna put what's on the
news and our take on it in front of you
is just um so mark brings up a really
great mega death song one um
that i i've taken a line from and sort
of like you know put as a post from time
to time if there's a new way i'll be the
first in line but it better work this
time you know p sells who's buying yes
it articulates a political stance and
not just a like party political stance
but a stance about
how society ought to work you know i'm
cool with being progressive and trying
something but it better not get co-opted
by the corporations or the power elites
or just you know human stupidity it
better work this time you know
um i think there's there's a very
powerful political statement there
that's a really good one i didn't think
of that but peace cells i remember when
that came out and i remember
my friend had just got the record and he
came in he's like yeah you hear the new
album yeah and i said no he goes it's
true he sells but who's buying and he's
like that's so deep
and uh i didn't know what he was talking
about because i hadn't heard it yet yeah
you know
well i love i love the the
first verses you know what do you mean i
all these things and then he's got a
retort to it you know um
what do you mean i don't support this
system i go to court when i have to you
know
right all those those sorts of things
um
well let's take this other one by carl
then we got to go to our our list of
songs that we are going to
bring up so carl says mark is totally
spot on one of the most interesting
things absurd i observed was a couple
years ago a friend from iowa came to
chicago to see the original misfits line
up an arena show with fear venom
and some other metal bands on the bill
and he's got the copyright thing because
there's two venoms floating around out
there at this point in time right
there's venom and venom ink
um dancing began spouting some ultra
conservative [ __ ] and the
overwhelming majority of the people
cheered him on and i remember feeling oh
what what what the f i was really only
there to accompany my friend but it was
an icky moment not of the
the night but among all the concerts
i've attended yeah there's there's an
interesting phenomenon with with like
seeing uh the people who we kind of you
know we may not necessarily idolize but
we thought oh they're really cool people
and then they spout stuff and you're
like where did that where the hell did
this come from you know
um i mean i think some somebody else in
another genre that people have been very
very disappointed with for a long time
is morrissey you know
um
for many reasons yeah yeah but when he's
when he's with the the smiths and i
guess even with some of his early stuff
he's he's
saying things in the songs that would
make you think ah there's you know
sensitive kind of cool guy
kind of dark yeah but then you know you
find out other
carl says it comes from people who don't
like paying taxes on their money that's
a significant part of it you know
people do change
uh as they move into a different tax
bracket but let's let's talk about the
songs that that we picked i don't know
if we're going to get to all like
analyzing each of them but these are the
ones that that scott and i hashed around
as being meta metal and they're also
anthems
and
um
a lot of them are actually the title
tracks too on albuquerque yeah i see yep
so the first one is bluester cult city's
on flame with rock and roll very early
one 1972
and we'll look at the lyrics for this a
little bit later then we jump ahead to
motorhead overkill 1979. you might say
well that doesn't have metal in the
title but if you look at
what the song is articulating it's about
the concert experience and it's like
it's also a great song because it's one
of the few that has two false start or
two false endings and then goes uh
into a final one all within four minutes
and they managed to pull it off you know
then we have judas priest metal gods and
we were kicking around hellbent for
leather before that and there's other
judas priest songs that do mention metal
but metal gods
i mean it's got metal right there in the
title and when we look at the lyrics
we'll see why it matters um iron maiden
running free scott and i were like well
there aren't any iron maiden songs that
are specifically about metal itself but
this one wound up being kind of a
an emblematic anthem not just something
that they would play in concert but
something that people would look at and
say yeah i resonate with what's going on
here
in this song
right
saxon denim and leather this one is very
carefully crafted to be about metal
identity as we're gonna look at maybe
we'll look at that one first because
it's so paradigmatic yeah ravens rock
until you drop um that's that's a good
one
venom's black metal is actually talking
about the metal experience and about
concerts uh things like that it also
helps to spawn
um the the early beginnings of black
metal
um this is one that that scott and i
didn't talk about and and i you know i
as i was looking around i thought um
wait a second what about anvil metal on
metal it's a whole album called metal on
metal that's twice
the metal is the band
and the metal is also the audience
so
metal on metal you know it's really
about that experience uh except shake
your heads
really works for this
um twisted sister you can't stop rock
and roll and you notice that sometimes
they instead of talking about metal it's
gonna be about rock and roll but it but
it's you know it is um that kind of you
know rock and roll that we call metal
and then we get quiet riots bang your
head metal health
will drive you mad
exactly yeah
um and then now we're getting into an
era where it's becoming much more
self-conscious and you know the next
band metallica named after metal
metal militia off the very first album
um we used to we used to actually i mean
it was so popular that groups of
metalheads would call themselves metal
militia or they'd write it on their
notebooks or on their jackets yeah
that's right
another one that
some people might be less familiar with
but i think is actually uh perfect for
this man of wars all men play on 10. now
manoward does have a lot of
this is about metal songs but this one
is perhaps the most metal of all of them
anthrax metal thrashing mad
that fits in there and then this is one
that we debated about quite a bit
uh with dio and scott kind of talked me
around to this one because originally i
thought like
um we rock you know yeah or stand up and
shout these two anthems that begin the
first two albums but actually rock and
roll children
i think
scott scott thought this from the start
but i i think this actually fits the
best uh and that's one that's kind of
late that's 1985. you know yeah that was
on sacred heart
and it's and again it's kind of like uh
that fills in the uh
identifying with right it was starting
to rain on the night that they ran away
they're misunderstood they have nowhere
to go but they've got rock and roll you
know
yeah so apparently in the video that i
haven't watched um
the boy
is wavering he you know he wants to be a
metal performer but he's kind of
thinking about you know leaving it
behind and she's you know more or less
saying come on man up you know you could
do it
and um
you know so
we should let's let's jump into the
lyrics for that one um
okay you know she the the uh part of the
uh
the um verse she was meant to be wild he
was nearly a child but they could only
feel each other
they were paper and fire angel and liar
the devil of one another right so
there's
all of this conflict going on
and then it's rock and roll children
alone again
rock and roll children without a friend
but
they've got rock and roll
that's right
so there's something about this
loneliness being shared together
and
what allows it to be not just two people
sitting in a bar or you know off in a
car together making out or something
like that is the fact that they have
rock and roll
and and when they have rock and roll
it's not just any rock and roll that
rodney james deal is naming it's
specifically um
metal you know yeah
yeah and you know with the imagery of uh
the starting terrain that's always like
they use that you use that in cinema
yeah like the rainy night
kind of thing
um
in a way this is a rare romantic um song
by dio right
yeah
exactly i mean it's still
i mean it's it's it's a story um but
there's no dragons in this right so
rainbows
yeah and as we know you know
even if it's night there can still be
rainbows in the dark for dio he can get
a rainbow in just about anywhere
that he can
somewhere in the night
so um you know there's there's others
we're going to look at some more uh
lyrics in just a bit and we're going to
look at some of the things that mark is
talking about but i wanted to mention
there's a lot of other metal songs with
metal in the title and so mark has some
here
like um grave well gravedigger's head
banging man okay that's referencing an
act of metal heavy loads heavy metal
angels in metal and leather that's
that's really really taking it to
another level we also have a of course
accepts metal heart
which includes a little bit of classical
in it
um twisted sister has a song called
heavy metal christmas and here we're
we're getting almost to like spinal tap
parody level right stuff
uh halloween heavy metal is the law
that's pretty cool you know that's
really cool
uh acid has a if you haven't heard acid
by the way the belgian band um that that
managed to produce three albums uh
essentially you could call them part of
the new wave of british heavy metal even
though they're based in belgium
um they have a song called hooked on
metal really good you know uh lee aaron
had metal queen i think she was kind of
capitalizing on it i i don't i don't
know have you listened to much of lee
aaron scott
no but i would say doro would be the
metal queen yeah yeah i i i kind of
think that lee aaron was
more or less cashing in she's not you
know girl school or or right warlock's
flashdoro
um she's a bit more aor
um
yeah hard rock yeah and then there's
also all sorts of metal name bands and
you know we know of course about
metallica
um there were the heavy metal kids back
in the the 70s
there are dozens of bands named metal
militia or metal force in the
encyclopedia metallic metallicum
and then we have bands that are named
after things that are pretty metal like
iron maiden right yeah iron right
chromoly
arguably anvil is a metal thing and i
think we could throw a tank in there as
well
so
i mean that that does you know when you
hear the the word have you ever heard of
this being anvil
um and you haven't you're not gonna
think that it's like
uh
a band that's playing like light soft
rock hits i mean exactly it's like they
got around some of the band names are
just kind of like
that's always the hardest part i think
for people it's just like let's just
let's just be so ridiculous you know
yeah
call ourselves anvil you're not gonna
see like a playbill that's like
hollow notes with special guest anvil
now i paid for a ticket to that
especially if they do sarah's smile
together
yeah okay so now carl says anvil wasn't
that the band that had the great
documentary a few years back yeah they
they did and they were
they were a band that um i guess maybe
they were a little bit before their time
in a way because they were doing thrash
when it was still called speed
and they never like broke their way into
the the you know top four
um that
really came after them
and it might have been wrong place wrong
time you know you think about the big
four it's all california or new york
right
and then of course europe has its own
major thrash scene that develops so
anvil being a canadian band
it's kind of tough in some ways the only
thing that canadian bands really have
going for them distribution wise is the
requirement that canadian radio stations
play a certain percentage of canadian
music
so that i didn't even know that yeah i
think i found that out digging into some
stuff about rush
you know so that gives you a little bit
of an advantage
um but going on with with like metal
stuff right so there's metal
um blade records um there were albums
with metal or heavy metal in the title
and again there's dozens of these in
encyclopedia metallium crocus
arguably a metal band just not a very
great one metal rendezvous in 1980
exciter another band that never made it
out of the second tier heavy metal
maniac
there's another band that's fairly
recent called metal lucifer and they
have a whole bunch of albums like heavy
metal hunter heavy metal chainsaw heavy
metal bulldozers so they're clearly you
know
capitalizing on that and then there's
some there's some other songs that
people who tried to capitalize on it
and it didn't make it
and um
i think the biggest offender and and
maybe somebody else might want to weigh
in on this um is sammy hagar
he he wrote a song called heavy metal
and it was in the
the film heavy metal which was not very
metal at all it was much more
psychedelic and yeah soft rocky
um and he he's got lyrics that
could have been good
head bangers and leather sparks fly off
in the dead of night it all comes
together when they shoot out the lights
50 000 watts of power it's pushing
overload the beast is ready to devour
all the metal they can hold you know and
then it's uh it's your one-way ticket to
midnight call it heavy metal
if a different band had done that that
could have been a really great metal
song with sammy hagar doing it
it's not bad
but i don't think it's really metal
i mean what do you think scott does it
does it qualify i mean it's got metal
all over the place
yeah i mean i think i you know i wonder
if he was approached
i mean a lot of the soundtracks
especially in the 80s yeah um
you know they would say okay well
like take
take the rocky movies for example you
know um
they would say to the band well this is
you know
um
this is the content or like peter sotero
with i'll fight for your honor to bring
that line of the movie out so i i think
they probably
said to sami hagar you want to cut on
this and you have to write it about
metal
um i'm surprised that he didn't turn it
down it might have been a lot of money
but
part of a cool project the movie right
right
yeah and but i i agree uh i would never
i i found i find sami hagar a great rock
and roll artist
montrose i would say is heavy metal but
montrose is with ronnie montrose that's
right you know that's right
yeah yeah i i agree
um yeah
that's funny about that though i do yeah
i do agree sami's
i wouldn't
yeah that he's i wouldn't call him the
offender i would definitely think
whoever produced the album or the music
for that movie i mean he probably took
the job and did his job
let me actually raise the stakes a
little bit asking what's bound to be a
rather controversial question
um so you know davey david lee roth uh
leaves slash gets kicked out of van
halen
and 1984
you know some of the songs on it i i
don't i wouldn't say jump is a metal
song
but house of pain definitely is and
you know there's others on there that i
would say are
sammy hagar joins um
van halen and he you know he's bringing
something to the band he's a decent
vocalist he's actually one that they
wanted originally before they had roth
um and he's bringing another guitar to
the mix which should always be a good
thing right yeah
is the stuff that comes after
he joins so like i think it's 5150
onward is that really just no longer
metal
in the way that we can say that like you
know even metallica at a certain point i
guess what they're still you know the
black album is it is it still metal or
is it more poppy
um i think some bands kind of move to a
point where we can say i'm not sure this
is really metal anymore you know
so sammy hager joining van halen does he
turn it from a
it was really clear core metal
originally uh
it takes it in a more
aor pop direction what do you think
well
that's a you know i've thought about
that too i remember when 5150 came out
and we hadn't heard anything about it so
yeah i remember true i remember that's
back in the day when you could do that
right right and so i bought this the
tape my you know my friends and i all
like piled up
like around everywhere and
could this be love or is that um why
can't this be love oh right right that's
it and it has that
using the scent thing and there wasn't
really
a guitar solo in it it was kind of like
that and it was
we were like what the hell's this
you know
but then you know like summer nights hot
summer nights by radio it's like
you know
we all wanted to learn eddie's parts on
it because they were great great guitar
playing but
it was like one of those whoa this is
not what i was expecting you know and
and then oh you 812 came out after that
and it's definitely songs about you know
how do you know when it's love and
um
he you know roth david lee roth was just
uh
a character yeah and he didn't you know
part of the lore was he didn't he didn't
care he was a great front person he
seemed oblivious to anything nothing
bothered him
and um
yeah the lyric con had changed i gotta
say though i i don't think that roth
ever put out anything so good on his own
as he did with van halen you know it's
as if he needed that
he could have other backing bands but he
needed that
band to be a part of they weren't a
backing band they were
you know they were uh
central to it um
i agree
so carl uh going back to the canadian
thing says glass tiger russian triumph
get huge uplay up there because of that
law my wife and i honeymooned in quebec
city
a year later the band that had the
number one hit was uh they twas a core
still sitting on the top of the charts
largely because stations were still
playing the hell out of it
um yeah and i mean if it leads to
triumph getting getting more plays i'm
cool with it you know
yeah i think they're really underrated
um i do too i think they're
amazing some people would say that
they're light metal but i i don't think
i think they're kind of like right in
the the middle you know
yeah i mean some
some songs um
you know some songs are lighter than
others but it definitely has that drive
of metal
um and the heavy guitars
um you could call their stuff optimistic
metal you know optimistic
you know that's good you can do it you
know you can fight the good fights you
know you've got the magic power in you
that's right imagine exactly but their
songs are just they could write i mean
that's i they
they definitely made it because the
songs are so great i'm kind of a softy
sometimes when it comes to uh music
stuff and i'm not exactly sure why but
um some of triumph stuff can actually
make me teary
listening to it yes there's someone
somebody's out there somewhere waiting
for someone yeah really great
songwriting it's just i agree
and what i used to joke what's with
canada and trios with people singing
super high range you know yeah them in
rush maybe there's a school for it
somewhere
that we don't know about i know
a little lab where they grow them you
know i'd be curious to know if they're
ever on a bill together
triumphant rush
it must have been i imagine at some
point in time i'm gonna look that up
later that's oh mark points out the guy
from razer too now if if people don't
know razer they are a
sort of underrated gem
another one there's we should have to do
a show on this sometime like why things
didn't come together
for certain bands that deserve more
airplay and listening to i mentioned
acid you know great band hardly anybody
knows about them
razors is like that you know
um even diamond head would have been
like that if
metallica hadn't covered am i evil you
know people wouldn't have been going
back to them and listening to them isn't
that the story you told me where
they they got booed for playing they
played i think they opened for metallica
right and they played am i evil and the
fans because a lot of the fans are
essentially musically illiterate
um started booing them and saying you're
ripping metallica off you know and then
the metallica guys had to come out on
stage and say no no no uh we our song is
a cover of diamond head song they did it
originally so sit down and shut the hell
up so they really did come out and stick
up for the band yeah that's a great
story i love that
yeah i mean they were there because the
metallica guys uh i mean what you can
say a lot of bad stuff about metallica
after the the cliff burton era but one
thing you can say is they really did
support a lot of um fairly obscure
classic metal bands that that might have
given them you know
the ballast that they needed to stay
afloat i mean diamond heads um brian
tatler says that am i evil has made them
more money than any other
thing and it's what allowed the band to
continue on and i think we could say
that for like blitzkrieg
yeah and and you know maybe budgie i
mean budgie had a career of their own
but metallica covering bread fan um
definitely gave them a boost you know
yeah that's a good point yeah like you
know we talked about maiden
um taking
lesser known bands on the road
yeah
yeah like like pete wade's band because
pete wade was his biggest influence and
you know how about steve harris yeah
steve harris yeah and uh how angry he
got when
the the crowd you know booed them and
told him to get off stage yeah and he
also says
people boo because he loves
journey
steve harris does so he said the pa
musics a lot of times journey yeah and
he says the crowd boos it
yeah
i mean what are you gonna do right yeah
um
well let's let's do some of the uh album
or i mean rather song lyric uh analysis
so do you want to lead off because i
mean blue eyes are cult i like them but
you love them
oh yeah
uh so city's on flame yeah my heart is
black and my lips are cold city's on
flame with rock and roll 3 000 guitars
they seem to cry my ears will melt and
then my eyes so right off the bat this
is just
it's yeah i mean it's like like i said
it's like hyperbolic it's like you know
you know
your ears melting like 3 000 guitars i
mean this is all so over the top
and then let the girl let that girl rock
and roll city's on flame
with rock and roll
yeah forbidden delights reigns of steel
and it's all right cities on flame
um
with rock i like this this line marshall
will boy but fender control right it's
referring to the technology that's being
used
you know
if you read a lot of moisture cult
lyrics
you you'll need references they were big
sci-fi fans they're big um
eric bloom said he was a big reader and
sometimes i didn't know what they were
talking about like astronomy yeah that's
but it it's well
well written
uh but yeah yeah that's kind of
i didn't when i used to listen to the
albums i was like what are they saying
here i would have never got that line
without the light yeah
and you know if you think about it so
you're being invited to participate in
the 3000 guitars right as an audience
member and you know part of
heavy metal
its gestures and stuff is playing air
guitar
so i think this is an early
example of
of a
meta metal song before heavy metal is
really being classified as heavy metal
yeah this was an early one
the songs uh it was on this one's on the
first album yeah
and they still play it
and the crowd goes berserk when they
play it
i got to see them play it here uh before
kovid at uh the potawatomi uh northern
is it northern sun uh it's been so long
since i've been there and it was it was
really cool to see it getting getting
played live
oh yeah it's great in that yeah the
whole instrumental part at the end it's
uh
it's everybody in the you know going to
a bloister culture i don't know if it's
like this way over by you but
everybody knows the lyrics to these
these standards you know yeah yeah they
can pull out anything and we'll know the
lyrics you know uh
you know the blue oyster cult
could probably
this goes to one of our older
conversations they could probably play
bigger venues if they only played
well they didn't have a lot of radio
hits but they only played the radio hits
and then did the cover thing we talked
about and oh right right and handed
cowbells out to everybody you know
yeah
with a little bluister called symbol on
it that would be kind of a funny uh
gimmick to do
uh but yeah they play the stuff they
they support their new
new works
yeah this tour they're playing five from
their new album which
i kept um telling richie who's the
second guitarist
i would text him and i'd say you better
not ignore this album on the road
because it's a great one and so i said
you have to play at least five so the
night i saw them
they played three of them and i go got
two more to go and finally he sent me a
message two weeks ago and he said
all right here's here was a set here's
the songs we did live we made it to five
from the album i go good you're gonna
sell more yeah yeah because the fans
will buy the vinyl and the t-shirt for
the tour and the kick drum had the new
album cover on it that made me really
happy that they're like
you know they've got a big catalog but
they didn't
they didn't um
they're not just resting on that it's
like hey we've got new stuff it's 2021.
yeah and here we go and we're proud of
it totally off topic and i and i don't
want to consume too much of our time
with this but one of the things that we
ought to do on the show
is reviews of recent classic metal bands
albums from like say 2018 onward because
like raven's got a new album like you
putting up blue easter cult does judas
priest has fire power
um saxon has a fairly new album
i think it would be it would be smart
for us to like that's great listen to
them and talk about it and also invite
people from from the audience to listen
to him you know we can
announce it in advance yeah but let's
jump back to uh so motorhead's overkill
i mentioned is about the
the experience of being at a metal
concert he says only way to feel the
noise is when it's good and loud so good
you can't believe it's screaming with
the crowd
don't sweat it get it back to you right
that's the uh that's the
preceding the chorus and then overkill
is is the
uh chorus itself
on your feet you feel the beat it goes
straight to your spine shake your head
you must be dead if it don't make you
fly so it's talking about the the
kinesthetic aspect
right
know your body's made to move feel it in
your guts rock and roll ain't worth the
name if it don't make you strut right so
these and that's it that i mean other
than saying don't sweat it get it back
to you and then overkill that's the
whole song and then you know eddie
fassetti clark playing his uh solos and
the uh
fake endings and then uh starting up
again yeah um
i think that's that's you know this is a
meta metal slug essentially
what's another one that you want to uh
focus on we talked about rock and roll
children in boister cult which is where
our book ends
what's what's one that you think is the
most important
from the uh
well we were gonna go to denim and
leather i think we should definitely
talk about that one yeah because that's
i think you're right about that
so this one i mean
it's pretty clearly crafted to talk
about the experience at great length
and i'm going to jump to
there's all these these things where
he's sort of challenging the audience
there's one verse where it says do you
dream of playing guitar or smashing up
the drums maybe you can learn to play
the bass and right after he says that
maybe you can learn to play play the
bass there's a bass phil right um
or you can be a singer like me and front
the band when on the stage we wait at
your command so this is you know biff
byford
talking directly to the audience at the
concert on the record
you know
and he's saying you can do this too man
you can be part of the experience
um
there's so much else in this song what
struck you in particular
well it's uh
you know uh after all
you know the lyrics you're talking about
the chorus denim and leather brought us
all together
so here we we have this you know
everything here is about we're in this
together you're not alone
you know this is an ex the whole it's
not just the concert or the record it's
the whole thing's an experience
um
[Music]
and denim and leather really were the
emblematic like early metal stuff you
either had a denim jacket or a leather
jacket or maybe if it was cold you wore
your leather jacket over your denim
jacket you know
i mean what else did people have there
was spandex for the band
but
most leather pants a lot more wearing
leather pants that's true which um
ungodly hot up in front of lights
and that's that's the title track of the
album which is kind of cool so
you know
that says something i don't think they
just said i just call it one of the
songs and we trust you on that i mean
it's uh
were you in 79 when the damn began to
burst i love that so it's kind of like
you know you were there but where but
you know you know about it but where
were you
um did you check us out down the local
show
and we were wearing denim wearing
leather yeah so it's it's totally
identifiable yeah um and it's
interesting because it's inaugural in a
certain way like you and me we were too
young to be at a metal show in 79 unless
you know maybe we if we had like an
older uncle who was into it who could
have taken us but i mean 79 i would have
been nine years old right so i doubt
they would have let me in even if i was
on somebody's shoulders but we can
imagine ourselves
being there
at that time and participating in it you
know
exactly right
um
yeah that's that's a pretty solid
pretty solid metal
uh
i wouldn't call it an anthem i would say
it's a
it's
it's it goes along with creating the the
community and you know you're like us
and you know this is going to reach out
to those people that are you know
for many reasons but either they're
already in it and these guys know what
they're talking about or yeah you hear
the lyrics and you're like hey wait a
minute i want to be part of something
i think that's a big thing in a lot of
these uh it's
they're not metal lyrics if we look at
all this stuff is not they're not gonna
be subtle about rock and roll metal
they're gonna be subtle about sex
they're not gonna be subtle about that's
right
drinking you know they're you know
they're definitely not showing uh
and you know to the earlier question
they're definitely uh
the different genres might talk about
drinking but not excessive drinking yeah
or a one-off or you know or dating or
you know it's it's
it's pretty
in your face
almost fantasy stuff even the love songs
there can be like multiple levels and so
you can talk about there being
nuance right but you're right there's no
subtlety
um
right i mean we can draw a distinction
between the two of those things
one of the things i really like about
this song is how it ends
it was you that's
set the spirit free it was you
that put us here today it was you that
filled the concert halls it was you
right so it's it's um in a way it's a
song expressing kind of gratitude or
acknowledgement of uh
a fan base
you know
brilliant i know it's great and
um you know deal always said that in
interviews
right yeah he's a very gracious guy and
he said he learned that he said he did
one show
and a bunch of kids uh were i forget
what country are there and it was
raining it was freezing and a bunch of
kids like about 300 kids waited outside
and they missed their train home so to
get richie's signature and he walked
right past them into a car oh and dio
said at that moment
my band i said to my band you s you know
you
sign you you come out and you always go
out and so he made what dio ended up
doing was um he said he played that same
venue years later and there was
you know maybe a thousand people there
waiting it was freezing so he invited
everybody inside and he said we set up a
table and we signed till six in the
morning
so
you know that's kind of uh that's a this
is a commitment you know and it's not
just a commitment to a lifestyle it's a
commitment to a community
exactly and that's what the song is
saying because he he says exactly this
he goes you know
we're nobody without these people
you know these people don't buy a ticket
then we might as well be in the basement
and so uh i thought that was really
i thought um
you know he said that's what he i think
we talked about what he learned not to
do from richie blackmore so mark has a
good good comment here there's a tension
in some of these songs uh emphasis on
metal fraternity but also an exclusivity
and often sharp divide between the true
believers and the posers manowar has
some cringy songs like that yeah
and that's right i think some of man of
war songs uh are cringy you know they
they didn't date well you could say so
let's jump to one of them that actually
is not bad it actually is pretty good
all men play on ten now of course you
can say this kind of kind of sexist
right
right because what about women can they
play n10
so but but it has kind of a nice um
narrative to it so it reads i made a
rock and roll sin when i tried giving in
to make money had to turn down loud they
said why be proud don't play so loud be
like us
and get a song that's real thin
wear a polyester suit act happy look
cute get a haircut and buy small gear
that's when i turned to them and said
hold it right there
that he says so here's the chorus well
it's more to me than just a job and
while i'm playing he won't get robbed
nobody tells a man how to play it just
ain't that way
that he says can you hear me say all men
play on 10 never going to turn down
again that's that's like the the
and some of that is yeah man of war is
always very over the top right i mean
big time in a way you could say man of
war
are they
they're not a parody band right so
they're not um spinal tap they're not
cauldron
but they're
peridotic
you know yeah or to use another word
that scott used earlier they're
hyperbolic and they're hyperbolic in a
way that
as mark's pointing out is kind of cringy
you know so
it's hard to draw the line between
doing that well but i do like that
notion of all men play on ten you know
um
that he that he's uh
he's got some other stuff but you could
you could easily look up the lyrics to
to see that which other ones because we
only have uh a little bit of time before
we have to
um get off which other ones do you want
to talk about in particular scott
um
well i mean
the quiet riot one let's see quiet riot
was one of those
um
they were so deliberate in their lyrics
it wasn't even clever
you know i mean it's just
you know when did that album come out i
was in sixth or seventh grade you know
that was
83 yeah we're not going to take it and
then the videos of course the time of
the 80s was rebellious
being rebellious against the parents
that wanted to take our rock and roll
from us and of course
with the um with all those hearings
um
you know trying to put us a
warning yeah yeah the led by tipper gore
uh
yeah mrc yeah
yeah
um
but um
got a mouth like an alligator i want it
louder more power yeah morocco it
strikes the hour
and you know it's like
another thing that we missed they talk
about volume
metal songs always talk about volume
that's true yeah
volume intensity you could say right
well spinal tap picked up on that
because they had that song heavy duty i
want to just make some ear i just want
to make some ear drums bleed and they
had amps that went to 11. they did so
yeah
they did and it could be their response
to man of war you know you play on 10
but we play on 11.
yeah
that's such a great scene
he's like rob reiner goes why don't you
just have everything on nine and make 10
the loudest and then nigel's completely
stumped like he never thought about that
and he's like at least go to 11.
but you know they picked up on the um
you know
it has to be loud you know and that i
remember um playing guitar in my
basement and one of my friends came over
and he came downstairs and he just shook
his head he goes turn it up what are you
doing
you know it's probably playing like a
maiden song or something and that was
kind of the thing it was cool to be loud
i don't think you know i i had a a base
that i had a 25 watt um practice amp
that had a 12 inch speaker yeah and then
i had a
200 watt power amp head that i put
through a 15 inch speaker and i'd play
with both of them and like run a
distortion pedal into the the smaller
amp and then just overdrive the other
one
i you know and i would play in our
basement in waukesha
and uh you know i'd only jack it up like
when nobody was home but i don't think i
ever went beyond eight on that amp
because it was it was so ungodly loud
with 200 watts and a 15 inch speaker and
everything in the basement was like
shaking you know
oh god yeah exactly
yeah and that was yeah that's
i did this you know i i didn't have i
just had like one of those
pv amps and it was plenty loud
but um i didn't really you know some
kids had the marshalls in their basement
but i i didn't consider it that that the
volume thing i didn't
that wasn't when i played in high school
or college that wasn't that didn't occur
to me
you know the volume thing but um but yet
i was listening to music that talked
about constantly yeah
well as we're as we're heading out um
let me just bring up one of them except
shake your heads
um
now you know it's not right it's
referencing head banging but it's not
saying you know uh bang your head right
um
it's shake your heads till your necks
are breaking the only way that that's
going to happen is if you're if you're
head banging right shake your heads cry
out as loud as you can
and why should you do that well the
lyrics say see the world around you deep
dark and gray grieving heartbreaks all
your life seems to be the way
wars of aggression mankind's favorite
game a press on the button a world in
flames every day and night and every
night and every day frustration's in
your heart like a one-way ticket no
return your tour apart and then it's
shake your heads until your necks are
breaking that's supposed to be your
response
to a world that has gone insane and you
know accept is writing this
in
1982 i think um
so you know
height of the cold war they're writing
it from germany which is right in
between you know the warsaw pet when i
was you know in the army we expected the
warsaw pact forces could come across the
border any time uh into germany so you
know
living there
uh that would be you know kind of a
significant thing this is sort of like
uh you could say a a response to war
pigs right except now it's telling you
to do something that's metal to shake
your heads that's the
response to all this [ __ ] that
you're dealing with you know
yeah exactly and to take it so far that
you break your neck yeah
which you know some of the concerts that
we went to
uh in in the 80s um i remember coming
back from them in the car and your neck
was just like
limp noodle from head banging so much so
well what else should we say before we
end i know i know scott you've got to go
and i've got to get to grading
unfortunately i can't wait to get that
very unmetal thing past
me um
so i
this is an uh this is
a topic gray came up with
a few weeks ago and i thought is is it
was fantastic and the more we got into
it the more questions came up and we
started with just saying okay songs
about metal but then
we went through all this and like okay
well
who's saying it and what's unique to it
and did it
did it create and like you answered this
i agree it created
uh
it created people
kind of being together but it also
uh drew in the people that were already
like that that wanted to be included it
allowed generate well not generations
but people
of different ages to
interact with each other and to
influence each other
and it was the times i'd be curious to
um see what newer bands are singing
about like newer metal bands um
i
i don't know a lot of the newer bands
it's harder to it's harder to reference
an entire community than it was in the
70s and 80s because it's been split into
so many sub communities
and it's hard to bring everybody
together in the same place as well you
know
so yeah well this this is an era plus
you got all us old people listening to
metal and talking about it right so it's
not a youth subculture anymore
no but although
we can reflect on the lyrics now where
at the time we might have been kind of
part of the lyrics you know yeah you
know like yeah dude like you know let's
party man let's go get girls let's you
know
where it's nine o'clock
i gotta go take my medicine
i know now it's now it's you know what
this this shows
that the music is that good yeah
because you know um it's outliving us
yeah but i mean like the music just is
amazing we didn't talk about that we
talked about the lyrics but the lyrics
maybe we would relate to it age 16 17 18
but i'm not relating to it now but i was
part of the era when i was relating to
it yeah
but that's it yeah i think
i liked this one
yeah me too i think it turned out quite
well thanks to everybody for joining us
and uh the great comments and
questions um particularly from some of
our regulars so yeah
we're gonna end it here and we'll see
you in the new year uh for for the next
stuff i i'm not quite sure what we're
doing quite yet but scott and i'll work
that out ahead of time and we'll
we'll have some cool stuff lined up
yeah absolutely happy holidays everyone
you